[Música]
y es el juicio contra william maxwell
expareja y mano derecha el millonario
jeff epstein que se suicidó en una
prisión en 2019 ya arrancó en un
tribunal de nueva york que este juicio
donde se juzgará así maxwell fue la
responsable de captar y además convencer
a menores para que el magnate abusar de
ellas la fiscalía describió a maxwell
como una mujer peligrosa que engañó a
niñas para así poder
ser abusadas por epstein sexualmente
además aseguró que entre 1994 y 2004 la
acusada explotó sexualmente a jóvenes a
las que manipuló para entregar las eps
en se presentarán los testimonios de
cuatro mujeres que aseguran haber sido
víctimas de epstein con la ayuda de
maxwell para ello quiero saludar
entonces en este momento a josé andrés
murillo director de la fundación para la
confianza gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
le preguntó si una condena pueden
reparar a las víctimas que tanto daño
psicológico y moral han hecho estos
abusos
la justicia es parte del proceso de
reparación de las víctimas sabiendo que
hay algo que es muy probable que quede
para siempre a modo de de cicatriz no
psicológica de trauma en la persona pero
la justicia no solamente es parte del
proceso reparatorio de las mismas
víctimas sino también
de todo lo como el imaginario social
nosotros estamos socialmente buscando
proteger a los niños niñas adolescentes
a todas las personas vulnerables que
somos todos nosotros ante estas
situaciones de
manipulación de sometimiento y la
justicia al dar un veredicto
y condenar a una persona como
ésta implemente caso la acción maxwell
lo que está diciendo es que está en esta
pues tomando posición en contra
del abuso y por lo tanto también
ayudando a las víctimas a saber que
ellas fueron víctimas y que no fueron
cómplice que no fueron responsables de
los que vivieron y en ese sentido si eso
en su proceso de sanación de reparación
psicológica cómo es este proceso como
una víctima de algo tan aberrante como
es el abuso sexual una violación puede
recuperar nuevamente su confianza
mira en un proceso que muchas veces dura
mucho tiempo no todas las personas lo
logran pero para eso así como el abuso
requiere de un tercero una tercera como
en este caso la señora maxwell que
utilizó su influencia
para apoyar el al abusador también hay
terceros hay tercera que son los tutores
de resiliencia pamos llamarle a los
tutores de sanación que ayudan a las
víctimas a salir adelante
a volver a confiar a conectarse con tu
proceso muchas veces psicológico que a
veces también requiere de
requiere de un proceso farmacológico de
un proceso de terapia individual de
terapia grupal para poder salir adelante
pero las personas cercanas en el primer
lugar que le crean que no la
estigmaticen que no la responsabilizan
por lo que por el sufrió lo que vivió
porque en una de las cosas que tienen
más presente en las víctimas es que
ellas fueron culpables ella fue un
responsables por no haber dicho que no
por no haberse negado cuando sin embargo
deja de lado el hecho de que ya estaban
en una situación de vulnerabilidad que
siempre hay una asimetría en este caso
uno de los factores de asimetría y de
manipulación psicológica es la señora
maxwell
y la gran asimetría económica
reputacional social a veces cultural que
logró que estas personas bajarán su
defensa y que no hubiese habido un
verdadero consentimiento sino una
manipulación de ese consentimiento
entonces aquí el entorno de las víctimas
e incluso la justicia la justicia es
también una palanca de superación del
trauma pero también es una palanca de
prevención para detener este tipo de
buscadores seriales le quería preguntar
jose si entonces las víctimas saben lo
que pasa entienden que están siendo
alomejor manipuladas cuando lleguen es
el momento que pasa por por la mente de
una víctima y sobre todo cuando son
menores de edad
mira
muchas veces la gran mayoría las veces
las personas que están sometidas a un
nivel como este de manipulación y
sometimiento no son capaces
de tomar la distancia suficiente para
saber que están siendo víctimas están en
una en una situación de confusión en una
situación de total sometimiento si ellas
fueran capaces de decir estoy siendo
víctima muchas veces dejarían dejarían
de serlo entonces el entorno el entorno
inmediato el entorno de cuidado
inmediato es fundamental para ayudar las
letras en ese proceso pero pasa lo mismo
muchas veces en situaciones de violencia
doméstica e intrafamiliar donde la
víctima está sometida a un nivel de
depresión
a veces incluso moral que le es muy
difícil tomar la distancia entonces la
víctima en ese momento no sabe que está
siendo víctima ni tampoco están en
condición de juzgar la situación que
están viviendo
jose ya para finalizar qué va a pasar
entonces con maxwell estas personas
multimillonarias con mucho poder con
mucha influencia siempre tienen a
personas como digamos en este caso de
eps en como maxwell para poder atraer a
sus víctimas realmente ella sería una
cómplice de jeffrey & sin
es una cómplice es una cómplice pero es
más en la persona que logra atraer a las
víctimas en cubre y que se hace cómplice
a veces tienen más por más
responsabilidad que el propio abusador
porque es la que es la que se conduce
con él la que logra la impunidad lo que
logra también el silenciamiento de las
víctimas aquí lo que nosotros
necesitamos que la justicia dé su
veredicto y diga sin lugar a dudas que
ella es cómplice de abuso de de
complicidad de
encubrimiento en el abuso sexual el
abuso de poder que vieron estas personas
y por lo tanto que está estas
situaciones son inaceptables para poder
también dar una señal a la sociedad ya
su familia ya las propias víctimas